these two scenes almost 20 years apart
both showed their digitally created main
character
waking up
they also served as the big reveal of a
technical breakthrough final fantasy the
spirits within was one of the first
movies with a realistic human cgi
character
at least in theory to our eyes today the
movement and textures make it look at
best like a video game cutscene
but focus on the skin
how did we go from lifeless skin to skin
that on elita a stylized character with
giant eyes and a robot body
looks so much better how do we make fake
skin
look real
that journey to realistic skin includes
pore mapping the appearance of light on
apples and chicken
and knowing the difference between a
glass of whole and skim milk
i'm finding it really hard not to feel
like a total stoner just thinking about
my skin so i'm like touching my face
right now
when we go through looking at this stuff
we're all doing this and like trying to
look in the mirror my name is nick
epstein i was a visual effects
supervisor on elite battle angel elita
battle angel is a 2019 action movie
based on the manga and it features a
stylized character that's perfectly
believable she's come a long way from
this guy the scorpion king from the
mummy returns
this shot is so infamous that the vfx
youtube channel corridor crew spent a
whole video trying to fix it there are a
lot of problems but a big one is the
skin the mummy returns scorpion king is
played by the rock you wouldn't know it
but elita definitely resembles the actor
who played her we needed to make sure
that we were capturing rose's
performance like the heart of this movie
was really rose's performance as a
leader so we actually built a fully
digital version of rosa and then we
could apply sort of our sort of more i
guess normal
realism factors and barometers to that
getting that facial model right is a
crucial first step for the skin's
movement when the hard work begins
i have four factors i think albedo
displacements subsurface
and then dynamic changes and
deformations and so on
[Music]
albedo is the base color map for your
character imagine the color of a face in
a void
no features no wrinkles no lights
shining on it see how i make the cheeks
a little red the forehead a little
lighter that bass is crucial to realism
and it's incredibly dynamic based on
rosa salazar's real skin they adjusted
elita's albedo map for different moods
health
everything so we could then sort of uh
compare the albedo map when she's like
really angry for example with her
neutral pose
and then extract basically like a blood
flow map from that and the shader could
then when she gets angry in her
performance dial in that extra blood
flow
displacement maps push the scan up or
down imagine how this little guy is flat
but features or a wrinkle here might
change the height of his face
look at all the detail in the scorpion
king's face here versus imotep's face in
the next shot that's the detail you can
see in the close-ups in elita
it's way smaller than wrinkles we call
it micro geometry even poor level
displacement that sort of gives you your
your the oiliness the specular response
in your skin which you can see even just
looking at me in the camera here you
know my forehead very different to my
nose very different to my cheeks and to
my chin unfortunately my forehead's
quite shiny uh my nose also shiny but my
cheeks less sewn that they're fairly uh
isotropic with it without without
direction i have a very clear flow
direction that way i have a flow
direction this way and have a sort of
reverse flow direction around my chin um
so we actually draw curves along these
flow lines
uh some extreme close-ups we you know we
knew that the camera was going to
basically fly into elite's eye but the
difference between this face and this
one isn't just the skin
it's what happens beneath it my name is
henrik van gensen and i'm the chief
scientist of lakshon makers of keyshot
and i specialize in computer graphics in
answering the question why do things
look the way they do and how can you
simulate it on a computer
[Music]
see when we wrote the first paper as you
may have noticed we did some
measurements in it so we actually went
to a local supermarket with a laser
pointer and we were shining on on the on
the milk we're shining on the meat and
actually the guys who had the
supermarket came so i said what are you
doing this is not good
the big idea of that breakthrough 2001
paper work that got the team to the
technical oscars was that the way they'd
seen light bounce through food was true
of almost everything and if it could be
simulated more quickly that would make
all computer graphics look more real
including skin
see how laser bounces off this spoon but
when i put my hand in front of it the
light passes through and even bounces
around underneath this drawing breaks
down as an illustration because light
passes through and bounces under our
skin computers could simulate subsurface
scattering like they do with this marble
but they did it by simulating every
single bouncing light photon that took
way too long so most of the time
computer animation couldn't bother with
it it makes the rock look wrong
light is bouncing off him not passing
through the skin it affected other shots
too in shrek they actually have a cookie
a guy and some milk and if you ever see
that shot it looks like white paint
which is exactly the example we said if
you don't do this properly it's actually
going to look like white paint jensen
and his colleagues figured out how to
simulate subsurface scattering more
efficiently that changed animation and
then in strike two they now knew about
this technology and then they went all
in on the milk so they had a ton of milk
but they now did the full uh sort of a
shop surface scattering and so it had a
little bit of an impact on that as well
but but milk it's funny because i went
to talk to sony
and you never know what uh what people
are interested in they say oh you're the
milk guy subsurface scattering could
efficiently simulate the different ways
light passed through whole versus skim
milk and also skin or at least the
beginning of it so when we created the
initial subsurface scattering algorithm
you're sort of based on this assumption
that you hit the skin and then
everything is the same underneath and of
course real human skin is not like that
we have different layers like epidermis
dermis and we looked at some of the
basic things that decide what human skin
looks like and it turns out melanin you
actually have different melanin types we
have one that's a melanin type that's
more on the brown side hormones want a
dark side you have to have mixes of
those to get the correct skin you can
actually do a very convincing now
rendering of of human skin
so you know i've talked about how we
define regions for micro geometry some
of the things we did also revolved
around dynamic scans so
we actually had uh footage of what scan
data so it's this 3d three-dimensional
data of rosa running through her harvard
lines of sort of every expression we
could we could ask her to
to do harvard lines are a series of
sentences that help hit all the phonemes
chunks of speech in a conversation it's
for audio but it can help artists see
every possible way somebody's mouth can
move when they're talking
i'm doing this video um
and it includes these things called
harvard lines
and i was hoping you could read some of
them two blue fish sew a button it
snowed rained and swan dive was far
short turned on the bent hook
early reviews for final fantasy the
spirits within focused on it as a treat
for the eyeballs since then increasingly
complex simulations of not just skin but
light and movement have made visual
effects look even more real the only
question
is how much further is left to go
take the winding path to reach the lake
note closely the size of the gas tank it
snowed rained and hailed the same
warning
the meal was cooked before the bell
rings
one of the immediate effects that sort
of the visual effects industry they
jumped on right away was if you also
have someone who's lit from behind you
see light passing through the ear if you
look at movies like like harry potter
adobe the characters are the first to
really adopt this technology they all
had big ears so they were very excited
about that and you see a lot of glowing
light coming through the ears